I was filming this crazy action series
uh in Toronto uh and that show comes out
sometime in 20 are you allowed to say
who's in that with you uh yeah it's uh
Arnold Schwarzenegger is the main uh
person fun to work with oh so fun so fun
did he know your comedy oh yeah we we
watch you do comedy uh yeah he like
posted about my he posted on his
Instagram about my special he's cool we
went to his house you know he's been in
all these iconic movies of course and he
has like stuff from those sets no way I
held like the Conan the Barbarian come
on I think he said his office has even
more of these cool movies not only from
his movies but a bunch like in his
office he has a stuffed version of
wheelchair